bitcoin's price has been going sideways
for months now and everyone keeps asking
what the hell is going on with Bitcoin
well if we go and take a look at the
data it tells a very interesting and
cautious story you're going to want to
pay attention to this first if we take a
look at balance on exchanges we can see
that Bitcoin has peaked in the beginning
of 2020 and people have been taking
Bitcoin off of those exchanges ever
since we now are at one of the lowest
levels in years of Bitcoin actually
being on exchanges this is an important
point because the more Bitcoin it's on
the exchanges the more cell pressure
there is it's very simple for someone to
Simply click a button and sell their
Bitcoin it's already on the exchange but
if people are taking the Bitcoin off of
the exchange it means that the Market's
more illiquid they're less cell pressure
and that's usually a very bullish sign
but the withdrawals from the exchanges
aren't the only withdrawals that we're
seeing we've also seen major withdrawals
from Bitcoin ETFs around the world as
well what you can see here according to
Bloomberg and UBS is that in April of
2022 there have been massive outflows
from those Bitcoin ETFs now any time
that you get Capital moving it's worth
paying attention to especially when
people are taking Bitcoin off of
exchanges and they're taking Bitcoin out
of these ETFs now ultimately if we go
ahead and we take a look the analysts
over at Block Force Capital had a great
point they stated that we've only seen
this level of outflow from exchanges for
previous times since the start of 2018.
three of those instances correlated with
a sharp upward movement in price not too
long ago but of course this isn't just
about Bitcoin Bitcoin operates within a
macro environment we must pay attention
to that macro environment Dylan LeClaire
from Bitcoin magazine coming out and
showing that US dollar currency index is
approaching a multi-decade high the US
dollar continues to strengthen against
foreign Fiat currencies and tightening
Financial conditions a breaking point
for historically over leveraged economic
system is approaching by Design and you
can see pretty much since the start of
2021 we have just seen a massive upwards
movement that doesn't seem to have any
end in sight now of course should we go
back to bitcoin you can look at all
sorts of different data points one of
the things that have the Bears being
very loud right now is that the 20-day
and 50-day moving averages they've
actually turned over and they're
starting to decline the past two times
that this has occurred we've seen
Bitcoin correct more than 50 percent now
if you look at this chart here you can
see that 20 and 50 day moving average
turning negative there was a 54
conversion right around 2015 and then in
2018 there was a 51 correction the
question is are we going to get that
same 50 plus percent correction again or
not time will tell history can be a good
guide for the future but it isn't
necessarily A predictor and so if you
start to look at where we are we have
some positive signs like Bitcoin getting
taken off the exchanges but we also have
some concerning signs like that 20 and
50 day moving averages turning over
negative so ultimately the question is
what's going to happen to bitcoin where
are we going to go from here if you
asked turd demister hit great point he
said that these charts talking about
that 20 and 50 day moving average it
draws valid parallels if Bitcoin could
not capitulate this time and hold above
35 000 it would be an incredibly bullish
sign his base case scenario though is
that given how weak Global markets look
there's a downward slide in Bitcoin and
a three to six month recovery of price
now of course this isn't the only thing
to pay attention to there's also tons of
things around the liquidity of the
market if we look at how long people
have been holding Bitcoin we can see
that a majority over 65 percent of
Bitcoin hasn't moved in more than a year
and still there's a large portion that
hasn't moved between two weeks and 52
weeks as well ultimately price is
determined by supply and demand we know
the incoming daily supply of Bitcoin
it's programmatic it's transparent can
be audited by anyone in the world but
that demand are people willing to
actually buy more of it well when it's
over 65 percent of it hasn't moved in a
year there just isn't that much Bitcoin
available in the market and so so
anytime that there's an increase in
demand however slight that it is
ultimately it drives the price higher
we've seen that with somebody like do
Quant and Tara and the Luna Foundation
coming in and buying 100 plus million
dollars of Bitcoin per day the price has
grinded up ever since they started and
until they stop my guess is that we're
going to continue to see that impact on
price but the big question now is where
will more demand come from what is that
Catalyst and can that Catalyst arrive
before there's any sort of weakness in
the market or up to a 50 plus percent
correction from here if you were to ask
somebody like James Malcolm over at UBS
he's got this quote where he states that
the vast majority of the population seem
to have little interest in crypto
because it's too complicated too
volatile and too strange so in a sense
we're stuck at the moment now of course
being stuck isn't good or bad it just
means that we're kind of going sideways
and whether we break up or down is going
to depend on a lot of these Market
structure questions and data points that
we're covering if you go and you look at
somebody like will Clemente over at
blockway he states that bitcoin's price
currently is finding a delicate
equilibrium between the short-term
holder cost bases at forty seven
thousand dollars and the hodler implied
price at forty thousand dollars the
bullish scenario would see a push above
that short-term holder cost basis well a
bearish cross would be a sign of
potential capitulation to come and so
lastly if we then turn to somebody like
Mark Newton over at funstrad what you
see him say is that Bitcoin looks to be
breaking a pivotal minor two-month Trend
Friday's pullback that likely causes
weakness down to test January loads I
don't know where the price of Bitcoin is
going to go next but what I do know so
you got to stay alert gotta keep your
head on a swivel bitcoin's in a very
delicate position right now a catalyst
could cause some movement to the upside
an explosive way because the Market's
someone illiquid but also the global
macro environment is quite weak and
Bitcoin without some sort of catalyst
could continue to grind down and
eventually capitulate and test a much
lower price you need to pay attention at
home because right now it's one of those
pivotal moments in the short to medium
term for price of Bitcoin nobody has a
crystal ball so ultimately being
informed and alert is going to serve you
well hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you're subscribe like the video and see
you next time